hi everyone welcome to another episode
of History of Science and Technology
Q&A and I see we have a number of
questions saved up here one from David
if eyeglasses were developed in Italy in
the 13th century why was the invention
of the telescope delayed until 16008
yeah I wondered about that too I I know
for example Kepler
uh wore
eyeglasses and how could it be the case
that nobody had thought of putting you
know a converging lens and a diverging
lens near each other and noticed that
that gave you a telescope how could that
have not been done over the course of of
hundreds of years um I think the answer
is that the lenses just weren't quite
good enough to have it work that the
lenses you know if you got uh
long-sighted when you got older which
meant that you couldn't read things up
close then um uh you know that had been
a thing that sort of until having even
the most basic kind of uh lenses that
allowed you to keep reading if you were
a monk or something or somebody who was
into uh sort of things of letters or a
merchant or something like this things
that could keep you reading as you got
older that was a big deal and the lenses
have to be that good um but uh uh to
make a telescope I it's an interesting
question how you would kind of
characterize the quality of lenses to
know you know what will make a telescope
that would actually be useful uh or not
um so I think that's the answer that the
quality just wasn't good enough even
though the the concept was there now why
people hadn't internalized the idea that
yes you know in principle you could make
a telescope but the lenses just weren't
ground well enough I'm not sure I think
that you know lens grinding became kind
of a was kind of a big deal and I think
in in the Netherlands where telescopes
were invented presumably um you know
lens grinding was was quite the thing in
the 1600s and uh oh I don't know for
example Spinosa famously was a lens
grinder by profession and a
philosopher uh as a kind of Hobby and uh
that was kind of the the high-tech thing
of its time I think was lens grinding I
mean it's kind of like people often say
oh you know uh Albert Einstein went off
to be a patent clerk um when you know
after he got his physics PhD and you
know was sort of toiling away in um in
obscurity the truth is that at that time
being a patent clerk was kind of like
being a an operative in Silicon Valley
would be today was kind of The Happening
thing in high-tech and I think lens
grinding was that in the
1600s but uh this whole question about
why things that are in principle
inventable don't quite get invented it's
it's often this kind of you know what
does it really do well enough to
actually work I mean we had a great
example of that uh in the end of about a
year ago with the large language models
of yes people had known about language
models for a long time I mean back in in
into the even in the 1960s people were
thinking about kind of the statistical
structure of language well but from from
Claude Shannon's 1948 is paper on
information theory that was kind of a
statistical approach to to thinking
about language and people have been kind
of constructing better embod better
statistical models of language but the
idea that you could have sort of an AI
that would write essays and answer
questions and things that was really a
matter not of the principle of the thing
but the details of whether it really
works
and I think the same is true I don't
know pick lots of different things that
sort of were there but not there I mean
another example would be drones uh the
the people the idea of a quadcopter was
a thing that had been there but one
didn't really quite have the battery
density one didn't quite have the uh uh
the kind of control fast control system
and so on to keep it stable so it's
these things where in principle you can
do it but in practice it doesn't quite
work or sometimes in principle you can
do it
but it isn't cost effective enough that
it gets gets sort of economically
developed and gets to be good enough
that it's really practical to use and I
I think it's always very hard to predict
that I mean I know oh one of sort of a
story from my own life I I am
um uh it's a story my my my wife is fond
of telling of of a time this was must
have been early 1990s we were uh
building some piece of some house and it
was a question of could one have a niche
for a television that was only 4 in deep
and I was like yes definitely
televisions will be 4 inches deep so uh
and now why did I say that well I saw
that I said that because I knew that one
could make flat screen televisions in
fact I even seen a flat screen
television from in the mid
1980s and it was kind of my assumption
that it wouldn't be very long before
there were sort of flat screen
televisions everywhere but turns out it
wasn't true took another decade for
there to be flat screen televisions what
did I get wrong what I got wrong was
that the rate of of of defect pixels in
a flat screen television was the thing
which was very challenging to reduce if
you make a a memory chip or something
and one of the memory elements is bad
you can kind of Route around it but if
you have a television where you've got
all these pixels displayed on the screen
and one of it's bad it's kind of like
you're going to see the bad pixel on the
screen it's going to be super
distracting and so to get the yields up
was a complicated engineering problem
which took another decade to happen but
that was very hard to predict it's like
uh so I think um um the
U uh the the that that's a um
um that that's one of these places where
you can see what the general Arc of
what's going to happen is but knowing
sort of when the details will come
together is unclear and then there are
things where
like for example in space for instance
there's plenty of examples where it
didn't quite happen because it wasn't
quite there wasn't quite the the
political or economic Force to make it
happen even though it could have
happened um and uh uh it's it's that's
what in a sense one of the things that
makes predicting the future hard I mean
the another thing is that you just don't
have the idea of something like that
being relevant or important or something
people will care about and then it turns
out that they do but uh in any case that
that um but yes I've always been curious
about the about the classes versus
telescopes but I think the answer is
lenses just aren't quite good
enough let's
see
uh goola asks are there possibilities of
researchers purposefully misinterpreting
history to support their current
research I often hear some things are
open to interpretation but is there a
case of this causing false
experiments actually I have to say well
there's plenty of of History being
Rewritten for political purposes I've
not I'm trying to think whether there is
history that's been written Rewritten
for scientific purposes I think there
has in the case of medicine there are
there are cases where people will
um uh talk
about oh how how some particular Medical
Practice was which yeah I think there
are cases there in in physics for
example
um it's an interesting question um I
think the uh you know I
suppose a case that I've encountered
recently that's kind of not really in
that direction is I've been very much
involved as uh in the idea of
discreetness of space and the our big
physics project which I'm happy to say
has made rather spectacular progress
over the most last few years
understanding the fundamental Theory of
physics kind of starting from the idea
that space is fundamentally
discreet Well turns out I didn't really
know this but in the early part of the
20th century kind of all the serious
physicists were sure that space was
discret and one by one they just
couldn't quite make it work and they
kind of went off in different directions
and invented big chunks of physics
because they wanted to avoid having to
address this question because they
didn't know how to make it sort of
technically work so that's a case where
although I didn't know it the history of
physics is sort of very much in well
people really did think space was
discreet and this idea that you know a
few academic Generations later people
say no no that couldn't possibly be
right is an interesting case where the
history was deeply forgotten and where
it's um
uh it's kind of went went in a in a
weird Direction you know there are other
cases like for example there's this
thing that's I I think has been most
popular in the last probably 20 years of
kind of remembering people who invented
things and tacking names onto onto names
for things you know unfortunately names
for things are often not correct and I
think that uh uh as a person who is
definitely um you know has had both
things where it's like really you're
going to name that after me and I I you
know I think I was involved in it but it
wasn't uh wasn't particularly My Thing
versus things where look I invented that
and you're calling it something
different kind of thing it's uh uh the
the kind of the the way that history
works is can be quite weird but there
are certainly cases where people are you
know often for ideological kinds of
reasons say really we should make sure
you know this particular person you know
we should make sure to attack the name
on sometimes it's because the history
gets done better sometimes it's because
there's a point that's being made I ran
into this recently the feminar numbers
which are uh kind of a thing that were
in a book by Fibonacci in 1200 ad
roughly um and but they weren't invented
by Fibonacci almost certainly they were
things that were kind of
known kind of among all sorts of people
thinking about math they they probably
were particularly known to folks in
India at a date that's not very well
known because some civilizations are
obsessive datas of things like you know
this document was produced in the 11th
year of the reign of Queen so and so um
and uh you know so there's a definite
date um and some some civilizations just
didn't date things so Indian and Chinese
civilizations I think generally
documents would circulate but they just
didn't have dates on them and so one may
be wrong by hundreds of years 400 years
or more about when something was
actually produced but there's some
reasonable claim that there were
versions of Fibonacci numbers known in
Antiquity in India and I think
there's there's some one could argue
that there might be similar things in
other civilizations we don't really know
I don't think we found any Babylonian
tablets that have Fibonacci numbers on
them so that's probably not probably not
a thing there although one has to
remember that when it comes to finding
things things can be very confusing like
for example the antia device this
Clockwork computer that dates from
sometime between the 1st Century BC and
the 1st Century ad was found around 1900
in a shipwreck of a uh small Greek
island um and it's the only example we
have of kind of computer is technology
mechanical computer technology from
Antiquity the next example we have comes
from the
1640s so it's but but just that one
Discovery kind of makes it clear there
was a whole strand of technology that
existed uh basically 1500 years earlier
or so earlier than we had imagined so so
sometimes you know somebody might one
day find uh some you know single
Babylonian tablet that makes it clear
that the Babylonians understood this or
that thing that we didn't we didn't know
about I mean I certainly have often
thought in some of the things that I've
discovered About Cellular autometer you
know programs with very simple rules
there's really nothing about those
things that couldn't have been done by
the Babylonians and I kind of wonder if
one day some tablet will be Unearthed
that uh is kind of the um uh the the
just those same patterns that that I've
made um in uh uh um the uh
um um uh in
um uh the you know that existed you know
3,000 years ago or something now you
know I have to say when I was trying to
design the cover for uh my big book in
new kind of science which came out in
2002 um one of The Inspirations for that
cover was kind of this Whimsical idea of
Imagine a cellular automaton that had
been uh you know carved in stone so to
speak thousands of years ago or maybe
even in Paleolithic times and was found
in a cave and then uh somebody was kind
of looking at this cave with a
flashlight and had this flashlight and
they illuminate this um this pattern
which turns out to be one of the cular
automatan patterns that was the original
inspiration for what became kind of this
rather nice I think uh cover design um
of a cellular automatan pattern with a
with a sort of shaft of of of yellow
light but it's kind of the Whimsical
sort of storyline that that came from
was this idea that maybe all these
things which I'm sort of describing as a
new kind of Science in this book um were
things that were really actually known
3,000 years ago but where people had to
sort of not join the dots to understand
why that kind of phenomenon would be
relevant and important for sort of
connecting to other areas of
science so let's
see
uh uh there's a comment here from Pierre
I think about some
um attribution the same for llm
hallucination today yeah I think that's
the uh um you know one of the things
about sort of the way that oh I don't
know academic science tends to be done
it's there have been different periods
of time in terms of the way that sort of
uh history of things is recorded I mean
it is a very typical thing for the last
I don't know probably 40 50 years now
just throw a reference in you know okay
let's uh and people you know accumulate
these sort of databases of references
and it's just like I'm writing a paper
about this let me wheel in my references
about that kind of thing and I see these
papers routinely now uh particularly in
in some AI kinds of things where
there'll be you know two pages of paper
and three pages of references and it's
like well that's interesting for
bibliographic purposes but it's a little
weird and um I think what I've tried to
do for the last I don't know least 30
years or so is I try to actually write
the history of things which is something
where you're actually trying to
narratively put together and I suppose
this this live stream as an example of
of uh kind of an outgrowth of that
effort is you know try and actually
figure out The Narrative of how did this
discovery get made and that's to me
that's both intellectually interesting
it's also very revealing often in the
actual nature of the discoveries why why
did people come to think this were they
actually right were they misled uh you
know who was the person it's nice to to
recognize the person who came up with a
good idea often when something's come up
with you know there are fields of of of
science for example where you know the
winner is the person who proves the
theorem for example whereas the real in
my view intellectual heavy lifting might
be even imagining that such a theorem
was out there and you know but but
there'll be a field where people will
just say the the winner is the person
who you know puts that particular uh
dots that particular eye so to speak and
I think what is more interesting and
more kind of useful in terms of
understanding kind of the The Arc of
what happened intellectually is to
actually write these histories and I've
obviously done a fair amount of that
it's a lot of work and it's always the
case that at the beginning it's like
there are all these pieces and you know
certain elements and actually threading
it all together is not trivial and
sometimes there are pieces of that
thread where there are very famous
things that turn out to be not quite as
they were advertised and there are
things that are very obscure where you
have to dig quite hard because you know
the person who did it was it was a
sideshow to what they usually did and
they didn't really tout it very much or
they died the year after they did it or
they or for one reason or another or the
person was sort of ideologically out of
favor in some way and they were you know
cancelled so to speak they and so nobody
heard about them or just a zillion
different things and um it's it's often
significant work to go and figure out
sort of what the uh uh what really
happened happened and more than that
there's it's when there are Big Ideas
they tend to be ideas that exist within
a certain context and the sort of
figuring out what the the precursors of
those ideas were without the context can
be really hard it's like look this
person said it might work this way but
they didn't have any context around it
and so that became a sort of isolated
claim that was was was really not it
didn't really connect to anything and
had one actually talked to that person
and in some cases I've had the
opportunity to do this in in the case of
some of these these things from from the
past sometimes you talk to them and you
realize yeah this person really
understood the core point they just
didn't communicate in a way that had the
context that connected to the things we
understood later and sometimes you're
like kind of shaking your head because
it's like wait a minute they they they
have this one thing that they were
pushing but it wasn't really connected
they didn't really understand how it
connected to anything else I I noticed
this a bit a chap I I wrote a long
complicated obituary probably the most
complicated obituary I've ever written
person named Edward fredkin who died a
few months ago um guess in the in the U
middle of this year um the uh he was a
person who had a bunch of interesting
ideas and he didn't really connect them
they didn't really connect and I and I
understood you know I knew him fairly
well and you know he would always say
this is an important idea and it's like
wait a minute you know for for example
he was very keen on the idea that a
cellular automaton could be made that
would reproduce the universe and I'm
like that can't work as such it just and
yet he was sort of very keen on this
idea and and sort of had various kinds
of uh but but it didn't contextualize in
a way that that connects it particularly
usefully to kind of lots of other ideas
about discrete space that pre-existed
and that sort of I've constructed and so
on it was it was this one sort of prong
that was kind of a separate thing which
which was had had its own consequences
that were quite interesting for
reversible Computing and and things like
this but so it's really hard to it's
often very hard to sort of do the
history and and put the pieces together
I think that there is a tremendous
tendency in modern Academia to just say
let's throw the references in references
5 6 7 8 9 10 and you know there's some
random paper the person hasn't even read
the paper I mean I always find it
amusing that people will regularly
detect that there was a reference which
had which was an incorrect citation the
page number was wrong or something like
this and it propagates kind of like like
a like a defect in the genetic code so
to speak or some weird feature in
biological evolution it will propagate
for for many sort of generations of
papers so to speak so it's kind of a a
funny thing the
um let's
see uh PR was commenting on the
replication crisis and uh how many phds
would be flagged for
plagiarism um yeah I don't know I I I
think I I have to say I I would say that
the answer is not as many as you might
think because I think this phenomenon of
kind of industrialized sort of hyper
pressure science that gets people to do
things like copy paragraphs from you
know from somewhere else I think maybe
I'm wrong but I think that's a a more
modern phenomenon I think that people
who bothered to write a PhD back in the
1960s kind of really wanted to write a
PhD they were not doing it for the sake
of getting to the next rung of the
ladder so to speak which I think is what
leads to a lot of this look it doesn't
really matter you know I'm just I just
have to uh you know fill the thing up
with something so that I can get my my
PhD certificate and go on to the next
thing type thing maybe I'm being too
cynical about that but my impression is
that that I think that less of a thing
now you know one of the things that one
always thinks is that oh in the past
everybody was terribly clever and
produced wonderful books and things like
this what one has to remember is that
the good stuff survives the bad stuff
does not and so if you look at you know
what books were actually being published
in the 1800s that say about science you
know there were some good ones which
we've heard of today we say look at
those wonderful things that were
produced in the 1800s but there was also
a lot of kind of very junky stuff very
derivative very kind of polemical kind
of nonsense etc etc etc that was also
existed at that time it just people
didn't keep it it it's um it's somehow
uh you know it's like the the used
bookstore phenomenon or something of of
how much do you you know there are books
where they show up a lot in used
bookstores and you say wow a lot of
people must have this book and you
realize those are the ones that people
threw out you know those are the sort of
popular science books that show up
because people threw them out I I have
to say I've I've always been rather
flattered that um uh my book a new kind
of science is comparatively rare uh in
the in The Used Book World um and
considering how many copies of it uh I
know you know we sold so I I've always
been rather flattered by that on the
grounds that people actually kept it um
rather than you know it's a it's a it's
book that has value in the used book
tray but hasn't shown up there as much
as as others and it's kind of that's a
that's kind of a sign of something I
suppose but um uh you know I have to say
that the whole story of sort of scal
dugery and science and and you know
there's plagiarism where it's like uh um
for the sake of saving yourself work in
there plagiarism for the sake of
stealing something from somebody else
and I think those are little different
and I certainly when I used to be in the
middle of kind of academic science back
in the late 1970s early 1980s
particularly at that time you know I
just scal dugery of people stealing
things was absolutely rampant now I have
to say I might have been in one of the
more Cutthroat fields that was particle
physics at a time when there were was a
lot of low hanging fruit Discovery to be
made and it was kind of one of these
things where sort of new discoveries
were being made every every couple of
weeks and so it's like who's going to
grab that piece of fruit who's going to
grab that other piece of fruit for
myself it was something where I kind of
decided I would we work on things which
are little bit less in the in The Fray
so to speak because I find it more
interesting to do things where I don't
feel like if I don't do it uh you know I
can feel like if I don't do it nobody's
going to do it for 50 years rather than
if I don't do it somebody else is going
to do it next week type thing but
certainly the the instances of scaly
were were absolutely rampant and it was
it it's one of these things that's
poorly sort of poorly policed I suppose
in in business there's lots of scaldy
that can happen too but in the end
there's there's much more in the in
terms of contracts and the legal system
and God knows what else that that tends
to be kind of looming in the background
that I think I think in in my uh sort of
imperfect anecdotal evidence I would say
the the density of scaly is is higher in
Academia than it is in for example the
tech industry although not to say there
isn't any in in the tech industry but uh
it's it's somehow of a different
character and somehow more um perhaps
more Insidious in in the um in the
academic sphere I mean it's complicated
and I have to say my own experiences of
this I realized only oh gosh decades
later that perhaps some one reason I was
more exposed to this than I might have
been is that most people they they
operate in a particular very narrow area
of Academia they just know all the
people in that area they keep operating
within that one area and it's kind of a
a a single uniform social click and one
of the things that I've done quite a lot
is to sort of enter fields from the
outside so to speak and that means one's
not immediately I have to know the
people in that field at least some of
them are often the leading people in the
field but I don't know the whole kind of
uh you know social click there and I
think perhaps that sort of entering the
thing from the outside which I hadn't
really internalized was such a rare
thing to have happened is a reason why
one ends up seeing more scaly because I
remember one time one very very
egregious situation of a person who's
who's no longer alive actually but but
um uh the um uh very egregious case of
just bizarre um where eventually the
whole thing had sort of come crashing
down and um I asked this person why you
know this was just an egregious thing I
mean you know why did you think you
would get away with this and the person
said after some pause they said because
you're not in our field okay it's
interesting that was a sort of an
interesting kind of uh uh uh I don't
know whether that was wasn't really
intended as a justification it was
intended for a you know why would one
get away with this so to speak by that
point this this person and their
collaborator sort of admitted that this
was a piece of pure pure scaly so to
speak so um uh I thought that was
interesting the uh and the whole thing
was very annoying as well let's be clear
but um at least uh given that it's going
to be annoying one Might at least have
some uh human and sociological interest
from the whole
thing the
U let's
see
um gool is asking what is best for
historical research photos text
artifacts depends on the period I mean
when I am sort of trying to understand
how I came to understand things very a
very self-centered view of History I
have good records and I have good
computerized records and so you know if
I want to know how did I discover this
thing I can often pin down you know to
the second when did I generate that
picture that caused me to do this and I
can I can see I did this recently
actually in looking at the history of
some things I've done in related to well
in the end the second world of
thermodynamics um where this was oh gosh
must have been
um sometime in the
1990s I was generating you know or
language notebooks mathematic notebooks
and uh you know they have timestamps in
them and so I was able to say uh you
know I generated this picture and I
could see in the next three minutes
after that that I got very excited about
this and I was generating more pictures
and so on so I could really see the
chain of of thought that happened there
and then you know an hour later I went
to sleep or whatever um and uh so you
know that's a case where you can really
see the the the chain of of thinking at
a very granular level right down to the
second when this particular picture was
generated and so on I think the um if
you look at different periods in history
uh for example the
1800s uh that I you know I will give a
shout out to the internet archive my
friend Bruce de kale who runs that for
all of their scanned material from that
period That's just amazing for
historical research that you can just go
and find uh kind of uh you know this
obscure Journal these obscure kinds of
things so that's that's a place where
read the primary material don't read the
I mean you know sometimes there are good
historians who've really uh threaded
things together in very interesting ways
those are those are worth knowing about
but I have to say in my own experience
go read the primary stuff the primary
stuff you've got to read the primary
stuff if you want to do any serious
history research you've got to read the
primary stuff and and sometimes that's
in other languages that's not such an
issue these days uh sometimes it's you
know in Gothic script in German and now
there are finally OCR systems that can
deal with that and there good
translation systems etc etc etc um and I
think then then you have sometimes the
challenge that people explain themselves
in ways that are completely alien from
today's ways of explaining themselves
and that's that's difficult to deal with
uh you know mathematical notation for
example since pretty much this early
1700s has been pretty understandable to
us today uh a few weirdnesses but but I
would say you can understand you can
even understand it back to Li Nets and
people like that um I would say that
when you get from things that are less
formulaic so to speak less formalized it
becomes more difficult to understand
what's what's going on um and uh
sometimes there are papers that are very
beautifully written where you really can
understand them sometimes they're really
incredibly badly written and uh just
very obscure and very poorly constructed
and uh that that doesn't help but it's
always really worth reading the primary
literature I mean I think that's the uh
uh
that you really can't do history
seriously without doing that now the
next level is going to visit
archives uh sometimes you can request
material from archives and you know you
you pay a few dollars and some archist
will make you a scan of something um I
actually find it much better to go visit
the archives when I can because usually
it's like okay just give me box number
such and such and you can go through box
number such and such and you often find
things that you never would have guessed
were there I mean many archives have
these finding AIDS uh which are kind of
just rough this is a letter from person
a to person B but you really don't know
what it is unless you look look at it
and so I think that's a that's an
important thing to do and and somehow uh
you know one of the things that it's
seems to happen to me almost every time
I visit an actual archive the archists
will say oh yeah you're in the tech
industry you know when will somebody
make a really good system for
maintaining online archives and I've
been slowly working towards that I
intend to do it for my own archives uh
to begin with just as a as a test case
but it's been a surprisingly slow
process I mean I think thech technology
we have now between our notebook
technology a bunch of machine learning
technology that we have a bunch of
computational Technology a bunch of
actual data on History that's useful for
kind of pinning things down and making
timelines and so on um we we actually
have very good technology and our
technology stack to make kind of a a
great archiving system I kind of my my
plan there is for example for me I have
oh I don't know 400 boxes I think of of
primary material that's it's all scanned
um and uh the um then uh the the the
issue is you have that material you can
look through it it's in boxes that are
more or less categorized the the
categories sometimes are a little bit
wrong sometimes there's a document where
the beginning and end of the document
aren't the same thing so to speak where
they got smooshed together in some way
they shouldn't have been um and
sometimes for particularly from early
years for me there's handwritten stuff
which is not yet urable but it will be
um and you know we we've tried over the
years actually to train machine learning
systems on my handwriting since I have a
bunch of that and I also have cases
where we have training sets where I have
a handwritten version of a paper and
then I have a typed version of that
paper so we actually have a a uh uh kind
of supervised learning kind of training
process to be done there but any case we
that hasn't yet been successful but it
will be um but I think the thing that um
I've wanted to do is to be able to sort
of take the raw data from these just
boxes of stuff to write narratives for
what was going on because I often will
remember you know I'll see some
documents and I do remember roughly what
was happening and it it's kind of like
let me put together these documents in a
form that actually makes sense put them
together in a notebook have some way in
which the the things you put in that
notebook uh are appropriately linked
back to the original Source documents
and so on I think that's the way to sort
of make essentially an overlay of an
archive that becomes the beginning of
sort of a a computational history so to
speak and and by the way you can get
lots of machine learning things to help
you in sort of piece together timelines
and so on and figure out you know when
was this letter was it before or after
this letter these kinds of things so uh
that that's I mean that's the kind of
Coming Attraction of what's possible in
computational history but I would say
from the 1800s the primary thing is
internet archive and and scan books and
so on and scan journals and then go
visit the archives themselves to to find
things in terms of of uh you know
photographs they are certainly of of
more human and Whimsical interest
they're less important typically in
terms of tracing the history of ideas
although sometimes there are funky
things like there'll be photographs of a
computer or a machine and it's like what
was this thing and and sometimes really
pretty hard to decode what it was
sometimes there'll be photographs of
people and it's like well okay those
people were on you know in the same room
at the same time and that tells you
something although you know I have to
say I've certainly been in plenty of
situations where somewhat frustratingly
you know one will be it's like oh yeah I
want to talk to that person I'm going to
be on some events and I'm going to be
sitting on a stage with them at some
some random event and you realize you
just sat on the stage for an hour next
to the person you didn't exchange a
single word with them and and you never
do and and so you know it would be
misleading to say well there's a
photograph for these people that sitting
right next to each other they must know
each other well not necessarily but I
think um uh you know what I found in in
in all the stuff I've done in history is
that there is always a narrative there's
always a you know it went from here to
there to there to there to there there
are there are really no Miracles there's
no and particularly in intellectual
history you really don't find a case
where somebody has a big idea that just
comes to them one day and that's all
there is it's always a story a decade of
development or at least five years of
development or something where people
are kind of moving in that direction
they're contextualizing things so that
they are ready so that maybe they see
something and then when they see that
thing they realize aha that's this that
really means something big but they have
to be primed for that and without that
they just don't notice it and when you
go back and you try and do sort of
attribution in scientific history it
gets very difficult because somebody may
have seen something but have no idea
what it was and it's like does Robert
Brown who saw Brown in Motion in 1830 or
something you know get credit for the
discovery of molecules well not really
because he saw brownie in motion but he
didn't know what it was it wasn't known
until around 1900 and it's you know so
it's these things where you can see
something but you don't know what it is
and and that's a uh you know that's a
feature of I think with sort of and then
you can ask the question this and this
is an argument for writing history
rather than just quoting references um
you know when you write the history you
can say you know Brown saw this thing
but it wasn't understood until 1900 so
it's kind of like if you're trying to
say well who was really responsible you
know who should get the um uh the the
browny points for that it's kind of
Distributing those in a way that is is
accurate rather than just saying up
we'll tack a reference in
here let's see oh there's also a
question from gool about artifacts yeah
I
mean that's an interesting issue because
that affects whether you can have an
archive for example which is a pure
scanned archive whether whether
photographs of things are enough or
whether you have to have the physical
artifact most of the time for me the
scans have been enough I have to say I
was writing historical stuff about my
big book new kind of science which in
the end discussed the actual production
of the book and I had to go look at the
printing plates which I still have well
at least I have a few of the printing
plates and you know look at them under a
microscope and that was to figure out
how uh how we managed to get certain
things to work and so on um that was
something I would never have expected
and and I'm glad I still had the actual
plates so I could pull them out look at
them under a microscope because when I
scanned them they were scanned at you
know whatever resolution uh you know a a
good resolution for for the human visual
system so to speak but not good enough
to be able to say oh let's use a
microscope to look at this in in more
detail I would say that in terms of
artifacts I in terms of learning The
History of Science well we did a project
in Connection in collaboration with the
uh national museum of mathematics in in
Manhattan that I've long been involved
with um we did a project you can find it
on the web um history of mathematics
project um uh.org or something um which
is sort of a precursor to a potential
gallery for Museum of math um that will
be a collection of mathematical
artifacts and so we were trying to sort
of inventory what are the mathemat
significant mathematical artifacts from
history and and that becomes sometimes
even more difficult to interpret than
written material like you'll have some
artifact that is I don't know some uh
some strange board that has markings on
it and so on and it's like what really
was this what did people understand from
it and so on and so it can be difficult
from from artifacts I mean we see this
in the most extreme form in archaeology
where we'll see some object from you
know 5,000 years ago and it's like what
was this we have no idea is it if we
have a context that connects to things
we do today we might say oh we
understand what this was it was a place
where they kept you know grain or
something because it it seems it is you
know we can visibly tell that it has
that functional form of a function that
we still do today but if it was you know
the the alter for the the god of ants or
something and had some special sort of
ant you know ant paths in it or some
some weird thing like that I you know
just made that up but but it's like we
would never know because you know the
god of ants is not really a thing that
is uh uh you know is is in wide
circulation today and uh so that would
be a thing with very hard to tell what
it was and and we see that you know
there are extreme versions of this in in
uh in cave paintings and so on where for
example are these you know handprints
black and black and red handprints and
it's like what on Earth were these I
mean what were they was it just uh kind
of um for fun or was it was it very
significant was it you know oh if you
are elected to the distinguished um you
know cave Society or something then you
get to put your hand on there what was
it it's not not clear um so you know
with artifacts that can be an issue that
it really is there is even less of a
thread of connection than there is in
written material uh I would say that the
um uh you know it's interesting question
whether there is written material
from yeah I think the amount of written
material that's just completely not
understood is not great I mean there
there are examples of that you can
certainly see that in kind of uh you
know secret and sacred writings uh you
know cavala kinds of things and so on
where where it's like it's not really
clear what this meant um but I think for
the most part written material it does
tend to be somewhat uh you know one one
can sort of decode what it's talking
about
um Isler asks the interesting meta
question uh what do you know about the
history of archiving when did archiving
begin that is an interesting question
well I can tell you a few things I mean
look the whole idea of writing things
down and storing records that originated
when cities originated when it became
necessary to have sort of organized ways
to keep land records things like this
that was ancient Babylon that was 4,000
years ago or something now uh so and we
still have plenty of the tablets because
they happen to write on on on clay
tablets that got baked in the Sun and so
on and you know you can buy them on eBay
for a limited amount of money there
there are lots of these tablets around
um you know I have one for example
little little thing that um uh is the
receipt for some it's actually a a kind
of a barley an option for buying barley
at some point in the future and um uh
some kind of receipt for that for that
option and that's a piece of sort of
recordkeeping that we still have uh you
know 4,000 3,000 years later or whatever
um other civilizations didn't keep their
records even if they had records they
kept them on let's say Papyrus or
something like this and most of those
are gone uh usually in in many
civilizations kind of the the sort of
the the uh uh you know in the in the
monument buildings so to speak there
would be inscriptions carved you know uh
uh you know whatever it is you know
Darius is the king of kings and you know
then there'll be a whole description of
of all of the amazing things that Darius
has done that's a real person from
Persia um that where a fairly famous um
sort of list of the achievements of
Darius and that was a that was a fairly
common thing to have sort of carved in
stone and so survives as as a in a sense
that's a I don't know if that's a kind
of archiving or not but it's a kind of
it's the way we know a bunch of things
about people I suppose another form of
archiving is is uh ferial archiving uh
you know whether it's you know burials
of people buried with things that were
characteristic of their time or of the
person or recorded their deeds and so on
and you know there were different belief
systems of whether it was the you know
the Egyptian uh you know come and be be
weigh in the balance type thing you know
the the the heart being weighed against
the feather type thing and and um uh you
know you had to have sort of the the
ammunition of your good deeds to help
with that and and that meant that those
things were recorded and kept in in um
you know as part of the uh funeral
material so to speak I mean I always I
suppose a striking thing for me years
ago now um you know one certainly knew
that the the the the purpose of all of
this uh sort of fancy burial stuff was
sort of for the afterlife and in a sense
you know it seems like a big fail in the
sense that uh you know people go to all
this trouble they put all this stuff
there and then it's just sitting in some
you know Stone enclosure in a pyramid uh
sitting there for for forever so to
speak or until it was stolen by some
some you know grave grave robbers type
thing but but I was I was realizing this
I was some Museum somewhere looking at
these Egyptian artifacts and you know I
realized well in some sense they were
absolutely right they have an afterlife
because they're sitting in a museum and
now 4,000 years later we know about
about their lives that we absolutely
would not have known about had they not
archived that material in in a pyramid
or something like this so so that was I
think an an early form of kind of
archiving Beyond life was which had a at
the time a nominal belief system having
to do with sort of the success in the
afterlife but in fact the the true
afterlife in a sense is the intellectual
afterlife of us getting to know what
these folks did you know 4,000 years ago
or whatever now in terms of of other
types of sort of maintaining records you
know governments have maintained records
Roman Empire they maintain records They
had um uh for purposes of Taxation and
things like this lots of records were
maintained for purposes of kind of uh uh
recording you know what happened in
government so to speak for purposes
sometimes people would so so I mean
those types of things have been
preserved I think that um uh the
question question of when uh well when
did things start getting sort of
preserved uh in in organized places the
Library of Alexandria for example was a
place where apparently there was a giant
collection of Scrolls from all over the
world that recorded that had all sorts
of interesting material it was a big
Library I mean when it's called The
Library it was really a university I
mean people like uid for example taught
there and um it was a place where people
would come to learn things and they
would learn them from humans and they
would presumably also go pick the scroll
off the shelf or whatever and go read
the scroll you know unfortunately the
Library of Alexandria was destroyed in a
fire um actually there were several
different pieces of the library and they
were destroyed at different times and uh
some were destroyed when um what was it
Cleopatra and Mark Anthony and and uh uh
Caesar and so on were having their big
kind of punch up and I think that was
that was one time when some part of the
Library of Alexandria was destroyed by
fire there's always this um and this is
where history gets so messy because um
uh you know that there's this whole sort
of sort of anecdote of history that says
that when the um uh
uh Islamic uh Muslim in Invaders to that
part of the world came in that they were
kind of um you know the the oft quoted
line is you know anything that was a
scroll in the Library of Alexandria um
if it uh if it's in the Quran we already
know it if it's not in the Quran we
don't care so to speak and therefore
they burnt the other Scrolls uh for for
for heat this story is almost certainly
complete nonsense but it's it's um uh
you know it's one of these stories that
gets told for reasons of sort of History
ideology I think more than anything else
um and repeated because it's a good
story um it uh but you know the actual
historical facts may be much more
complicated and may involve yes there
was you know a belief that certain kinds
of things they didn't want these kinds
of Scrolls there they believed in this
they believed in that there was sort of
uh pressure of this kind and this who
knows but um uh it's it's um these kind
of the the the quick versions of History
are usually not right but any case so
Library of Alexandria was another was
sort of an early example of um a place
where people were trying to collect kind
of knowledge archiving so to speak um
the uh I would say that the the the
real period of time when that really got
started was things like the bodan
library in Oxford and
uh oh what is it bibliotech national
something in in Paris maybe um I think
at the time when the University were
getting started in in Europe in the
1200s um I think there was sort of the
beginnings of that kind of thing um I
think I'm trying to remember maybe the
ban Library dates from the 1600s I'm not
sure um but there was kind of a a um uh
this idea of of keeping
material uh was something that I think
by the time okay so the British museum
was founded I think in the early
1800s um and uh sort of there was a big
sort of period of museumification that
happened by the mid to late 1800s things
like the Natural History Museum in
London and so on but um you know things
like the British museum which were were
keeping artifacts I think in the in the
period in the late 1700s early 1800s
there was sort of a a an interest in
looking back at history I mean you know
at different times in history there have
been sort of political regimes which say
sort of forget all of history we can
invent everything for ourselves and the
modern is all is the only thing that's
good and there have been other times
when it's like we are rooted and our
credibility comes from our rooting in
history so to speak and so both of these
things are forces that one seen in in in
in sort of political history and I think
people like Napoleon for example were
Napoleon was very big on on egyptology
and kind of the the uh in a sense the
cultur ification through sort of the
connection to this grander culture of
the past so to speak uh and and Napoleon
was responsible for bringing whole bunch
of Egyptian artifacts to Paris and then
when the British kind of uh
uh won those Wars then a bunch of that
stuff wound up at the British Museum and
um you know these Cleopatra's needles
that show up and there's one in London
there's one in New York I think there's
one in Paris um I think there were quite
a lot of these things available in Egypt
I think you didn't although kind of the
concept of of oh we're just going to
take this giant you know very many ton
Rock and just sort of take it out of
here um it's it's hardly as if that was
done you know it must have involved a
lot of donkeys and a lot of you know a
lot of these are not easy things to sort
of pick up and and put in your backpack
type thing um but in any case the the um
that was a period I think the 1800s was
um you know that there was a late 1700s
early 1800s there was a big period where
people got interested in sort of
maintaining history in that way I mean
certainly the historical sites even were
often just like oh well you know in Rome
for example lots of historical buildings
people would scavenge The Rock from them
you know the stones from them and so on
it wasn't until much later that that was
sort of there was an effort to preserve
that history I would say that in in
terms of kind of the archiving of uh oh
things like
uh papers that people have produced I
mean
usually papers get preserved in
complicated ways so for example it's
always a amusing that there will always
be this term you know the so and so
nlas U German term which means I think
suitcase and sometimes it really is
literally that um for example Charles
Babbage uh early sort of engineer
originator of of mechanical computers um
lived in the in the U first half of the
1800s mostly um was uh there was a thing
was always called there was a bunch of
material from him that was in you know I
happen to research his history quite a
bit was in the cowhide trunk okay what
was the cowhide trunk well I actually
got to see the cowhide trunk it's in the
Museum of History of Science in Oxford
um and well what had happened to it what
happened was when when babage died
his lawyer had wound up with this
material from babage a bunch of papers
bunch of plans of the analytical engine
and so on that were in the cowhide trunk
well what happened to the cowhide trunk
well it was actually in the playroom of
the kids of the lawyer for pretty much a
generation and at some point somebody
opened the cowhide trunk and said oh
there's a bunch of drawings in here I
don't know exactly what happened next
but eventually they wound up at this
this Museum so are weird things like
that that happen I mean for example in
um oh you know there are people who will
contact me for example and say oh my
grandfather or great-grandfather or
something was some well-known scientist
and I've got tons of boxes in the Attic
that were from this person and it's like
okay that's great they they you know
they've been found they're they're
probably good places to to keep them it
can also be very complicated uh you know
there are things where things will get
scattered to the winds and then will
show up again in very uh very kind of in
complicated ways so for example the
Babylonian astronomical Diaries the
longest running science experiment in
history 700 years of astronomical
observations the we have about couple of
percent because they were daily
observations so we know how many of they
were taken we have a couple of percent
of those tablets where do they come from
they came because people bought them and
random Antiquities deers around
1900 and they presumably were in one
place maybe they were in one place maybe
they were in several places but by the
time you know maybe they had been
excavated maybe one 200 years earlier
but then they'd been scattered to the
winds and people were just buying these
oh here's a cool Babylonian tablet I
don't really know what it says and then
eventually people uh particularly couple
of people really tried to go and find
all these Babylonian tablets and piece
together the ones that were the as rical
Diaries so they kind of got
reconstructed that way for example I uh
well this is a story of my own I I wrote
about this in some some piece I wrote uh
oh 2019 I think um I was was a a former
High School teacher of mine who um uh
well let's see how did this go there was
a a a former High School teacher of mine
who died who um gave a book to another
former High School teacher of mine uh
with the statement that it should get
given to some appropriate person uh in
in due time so to speak and so the the
second High School teacher of mine gave
this book to me in 2019 and it's a book
it's a quantum mechanics book it was
originally owned by a chap called Norman
routage who was a high school teacher of
mine but had have been a friend of Alan
Turing so okay so I I get this book and
it's it's you know I actually have
another copy of this book it was D's
quantum mechanics book and I'm leafing
through this book as you know person's
handing it to me breakfast I was having
with them and uh I Le through it and
there's a piece of paper in it and it's
like and it has it has this is a book
about quantum mechanics and it's a book
oh I should explain that this book was
had been owned by Alan touring um and uh
had gone from Alan touring to Norman
routage and from Norman routage to this
this other teacher of mine and then then
to me and um the uh uh so it has this
piece of paper in it and this piece of
paper had something which I could
recognize was mathematical logic so
that's pretty weird that you have this
book that was own bent touring and and
then it ends up being a book about
quantum mechanics and it then has this
page of mathematical logic and it's like
did Alan touring write this page and so
I look up the sort of handwriting of
aluring and I couldn't tell where it
really matched I know a handwriting
expert who said she didn't think it
matched um but then I kind of went into
the sort of Deep dive of what could you
tell about this book well it had a
bookmark in it and the bookmark came
from a bookstore in Cambridge and the
bookstore in Cambridge had a telephone
number on the bookmark and the telephone
numbers changed at different times so
you could tell when this bookmark was
from and so on and then there was a oh
that's right there was a piece of paper
that had a watermark that was from a a
German Journal that um had been uh
published only you know started
publication at a certain time anyway a
whole long chain of of events in the end
the piece of paper wasn't written by
Alan Turing it was written by a person
called Robin gandhy um who was a student
of of touring um but uh in any case that
that was a case where it's like you know
how do you actually
go the sort of this archive in a sense
that piece of paper wasn't an archive
it's just free floating and and there
are you know I have a bunch of of
documents for instance that yes I have
pretty good archives myself but there
documents that are sort of fragments
from archives that where they're quite
substantial archives somewhere else like
I have a bunch of material that dick fan
gave me um that uh and I that which is
you know sort of my little fragment of
of something which would be a larger
Archive of of of his work but um uh you
know so I think the
and and things get very complicated with
archives because for example um there
are questions like who owns this
material so for example one that I
happen to know a little bit about is AD
Love's archive which some part of which
wound up at the Balan uh uh library in
in Oxford and um the there's a
complicated there was I think it's now
resolved sort of a complicated mess
going on between the ad Love's
descendants and the library and you know
it had been stuck in this Library
sometime in the late 1800s and it's been
sitting there for you know 100 years or
more and uh it's kind of like okay um
but what happens to it who owns it well
maybe it's actually owned by the
Descendants and it's probably worth a
lot of money and so then the question is
well can you just sell it you know maybe
it's worth I don't know $20 million
let's say can you just sell it and then
you know somebody gets the $20 million
and it goes to some happy collector's
home rather than to a kind of a a
general long-term Library well then of
course things get more complicated
because uh you know there's a lot of
forces at work so it's like well you
know most of the collectors are American
or maybe Asian and um uh you know then
the the British government can declare
that these are documents that are of in
the National you know they're sort of
National Treasures they can't leave the
country and so that then puts a whole
constraint on the thing and then it
becomes a whole negotiation I'm not sure
what happened in that particular case um
because I was looking at that material
um in 2015 I haven't haven't looked at
it since
um but uh uh any
case
so gosh let me
see
um
let's
see baby is
commenting um that what we've been
talking about today pinpoints how
critical it is for scientists to know
the history history of their field as
well as become excellent
communicators
um
the yeah they're commenting that that
I'm correct in my in my observation that
people just have the sort of the bank of
references and and wheel out the
references uh to sort of fulfill an
obligation you know it's a funny thing
the history of scientific publishing
because back when scientific publishing
was first really being developed which
was essentially the proceedings of the
Royal Society and uh edited by uh I
guess Edmund hle originally um that was
in the
1650s 16 60s or something and uh it was
really if you read the early early
volumes of the proceedings of the Royal
Society it was very kind of whimsical it
was very much you know I saw a goat that
had you know horns that were shaped like
this or I saw a flash of green right at
the moment when the sun rose over the
Alps and then it had some extra color
because you know uh but my view was
obscured by the fact that you know
a I don't know a herd of cows came out
at that time or something but it had it
had this kind of whimsical extra color
in it um and I think what happened over
the years is that in sort of the
professionalization of science there was
sort of this belief that things and and
perhaps also a little bit you know
science had many influences you know in
in in various periods of time Germany
was sort of the top country with France
sort of run around and the UK as an even
you know as as a further runner up and
then the US kind of entered the scene in
the 20th century and uh you know each of
those countries had a certain cultural
uh left a certain cultural imprint on
the way that science was communicated
and and done and I think to some extent
the the sort of ultr
professionalization of let's make it
sound very official uh perhaps that was
you know the French style is a bit on
the formal side particularly in
mathematics the American style could be
something of the is a little bit funny
for a country that was sort of from from
so many pioneers but it became at some
point the very sort of ultr
professionalized version where things
had to sound very official um and uh uh
you know where even the most basic um um
sort of ideas were couched in these
complicated words and jargon and so on
um and and that's become something that
you know is is a feature of science it's
a feature of other fields even
Philosophy for example went from kind of
a time when people wrote Things in sort
of plain language to a time when they
would write it in terms of layers of
jargon so to speak I think that often
that is done for you know for the
appearance of professionalization so to
speak and more cynically it's sometimes
done because people actually don't know
what they're talking about and if they
were forced to explain those things in
simple terms they would fall apart I
mean it just wouldn't be they wouldn't
be explainable I know in my own uh sort
of story of trying to explain things uh
for me it's an important constraint that
I try to explain things as sort of
Simply as I can because once I can do
that I actually have confidence that I
understand the things myself and any
time where I fall back on oh there's a
technical formal way to describe this
it's and that's the only thing I can say
it's a super bad sign and I know myself
well enough to know that's something I
don't really understand that well and
and I think that but it's somehow you
know if you know that formalism it can
be easier to to to be at that level
rather than saying let me break it down
into sort of these these simplest
component parts but I think it's a big
shame in many ways that sort of
scientific communication evolved to the
point where so much I think there's been
a little bit of a trend backwards in in
more recent years where people don't
just write a paper that just just says
you know Smith and Jones showed X and Y
now we're going to show Z that's a small
increment of that but they're not really
explaining why they're doing this why
anybody would care um there's there's a
bit more sort of there's some pressure I
think from some journals and so on to
say you know why would we care about
this and that I think is very worthwhile
um in my own form of communication I
sort of have decided that um uh in my
efforts to uh sort of eek out a certain
amount of time to write things and I end
up writing a fair amount but you know
I've done that in a very free form way
um where I kind of just can have defined
a way of of writing things that lets me
write kind of technical things WR lets
me write narrative kinds of things and I
I don't feel any compunction not to make
the Whimsical point right in the middle
of some quite technical thing because
I'm not you know I feel like I don't I'm
I'm not trying to prove how professional
it is so to speak I don't think that's
really the point I'm just trying to
communicate what I'm trying to
communicate I think also in terms of the
history side of it what I found is that
that I say many things I've done I've
really tried to dig into the history
sometimes in a kind of I suppose it's
not really a um it's a a variant of the
wheel in lots of references I've made
bibliographies of of fields like did
that for combinators and for post tag
systems and things like this where I
really tried to go through and just get
the complete story what were all the
papers published in this field in the
last 100 years um since the thing was
originated and in in these sort of
fairly small areas one's able to do that
and I think it's it's sort of useful to
see the flow of those bibliographies I
think it's less useful than seeing the
narrative history but it's sort of
useful but when you have bigger Fields
where there are just you know 10,000
100,000 papers whatever in this field
it's just hopeless I mean the only way
you're ever going to understand things
is to try and actually piece together a
narrative
history
um ah it's an interesting question from
conformal here what has history taught
us on how to deal with the science
community that is
misguided
um that's an interesting question I mean
I can think of many misguided
uh moments in science some quite
unsavory uh like the Eugenics movement
of the early early 20th century um and
uh or phenology you know the shapes of
heads and things and um uh uh as a as an
indicator of of uh human characteristics
things like that
um I
think you know it's complicated because
there are plenty of things where people
have been viciously attacked for what
seemed like nonsense like the person who
gosh what is their name in in maybe
Austria or Germany who uh kind of sort
of understood the germs theory of of
transmission of disease and was you know
a doctor in a hospital and they were
like you really should wash things so to
speak and and people didn't and and but
and eventually there was such a sort of
this person is non is crazy you know
they're talking about unseen you know
things that carry disease that you know
this has to be you know this they have
to be nuts and um uh and of course it
turned out they weren't nuts and in fact
they were quite right but you know and
there are plenty of examples of people
who sort of see a truth so to speak and
don't and other people don't see it I
mean I have to say in my own life and
times I've had plenty of examples of
that that where it's kind of like you
know there's something which you know
because of things I've tried to figure
out or whatever seems kind of obvious to
me but yet people say no no no it can't
be true you know because we know it
isn't true because because there's this
whole stack of scientific papers that
assume it isn't true it's not like it's
proved it isn't true it's just we assume
it isn't true and people have built a
lot on the assumption that it isn't true
I think you know Max plank I think uh
who had his own issues I would say
um was uh I think he has a quote that
the progress of science is measured in A
procession of funerals so to speak by
which he meant that people hang on to
some belief about how things work and
they'll hang on to it their whole career
and it's only when the next Generation
comes in that that can change and uh
maybe that's a little little bit of of
the answer you just have to wait uh and
you know it's a little bit it maybe uh
you know it perhaps is damaging for
society that they have to wait another
50 or 100 years it's disappointing for
The Originators of the ideas because
they're dead by the time anybody says oh
yeah that was a clever idea type thing
um I mean that's a that's a a feature of
of uh inventing things that are sort of
uh ideas from the future is typically
you won't be around at the time when
people realize oh yeah that really was a
good idea it's a shame but uh um you
know it's it's it's it's in a sense it's
it's at least fun to be able to see the
future um even if you don't uh uh get a
pat on the back for for being for being
right I think that
um
uh well let's see what are some examples
of um I'll give you an example I mean I
think
I would say
that yeah it's complicated I mean there
are things even that I've originated
where people have run off and done
things that I think were kind of silly
with the things that I've originated I
mean that happened a bunch in kind of
complexity Theory and so on of things
that were kind of uh sort of ideas and
discoveries of mine that then got
applied to things where like that's not
a very good application that's not a
sensible thing I don't think I have a
good thing to with that other than I
don't think and it's very complicated
because if you just say oh it's all
nonsense kill it all that's not really a
positive thing to do because you've got
a field that is a a young field that's
sort of struggling to survive and it's
doing a few kind of crazy things but
it's like you don't want to kill off all
those things you you want to allow some
degree of kind of of craziness because
maybe some of those crazy things will
turn out to be right also just the very
fact that they're being done under the
banner of the field is important for the
future development of the field
so I think the only you know perhaps uh
you just wait but you might have to wait
a 100 years for sort of the the the
misperception to be kind of worked
through I think the other thing well the
other thing realistically
is uh just you know do what you believe
so to speak and the fact that lots of
people are telling you oh it couldn't
possibly be true because you know
there's this whole Orthodoxy that builds
up about how that couldn't possibly be
true if you've got a good reason to
believe it and you really you know you
believe in your own sort of tower of
belief so to speak then I think you know
go for it kind of thing and it uh you
know what does it take to sort of move
the Orthodoxy in that
direction I'm not sure I mean I've I've
been in the middle of that a bunch of
times and you know I think it's sort of
a gradual increase in the number of
people who can do things with the
particular direction you've defined and
then that eventually starts taking over
it's very rarely the case you know you
would think with all the sort of story
of falsifiability and Science and so on
you get to a point in some experiment we
done it's like Kaboom that's the
definitive experiment it goes this way
or it goes that way that isn't so often
the case because the experiments are
difficult and their interpretation is
not so easy I mean there are cases where
this has happened the discovery of the
cosmic microwave background was one
example where it's like Kaboom there
really was you know Big Bang hot early
Universe type thing the steady state
Theory really isn't the story that was a
case where I think that really did I I
don't know that history perfectly but I
think that was a case in 1964 where the
um uh where it really did sort of an
experiment which wasn't an experiment
where people were doing it they weren't
doing the experiment to say are we going
to find Theory a or Theory B they were
trying to communicate with satellites
and finding out that there was a
background noise that they couldn't get
rid of um and then were sort of smart
enough to realize to have the context to
think about is this relevant to
cosmology so to speak but I think that
um uh this this you know you might think
well we got Theory a and Theory B and
we're just going to do the of experiment
and we're going to figure out which
theory is right that doesn't play out as
cleanly as you think most of the time
because the experiments are difficult
the experiments have gotten wrong the
people who do the experiments are sort
of gunning for a particular result and
they'll keep tweaking things until they
get that result and often when the
experiment is difficult it's right on
the edge and it's right at the you know
the thing you can only just SL starts at
attack so to speak you know I think most
people I think by this point believe the
validation of Einstein's general theory
of relativity by by Arthur Edington and
and friends was probably not really
right that that experiment was kind of
like you know tweaked to show the theory
was correct because they wanted to show
the theory was correct um and uh you
know that can happen very often it's
very difficult to you know it's um so
you know I think this this
um this idea that you know we'll just do
the experiment and that'll prove it to
them and then then everybody will happy
it often doesn't work that way uh and um
so you know I think um you know what
other the things about the scientific
Community I mean you know there are all
these things that happen where
people unfortunately there are often
forces from Beyond science that impinge
on on science that are very difficult
for science to deal with I mean there
are things where whether it's you know
politics uh usually is politics of some
kind where there's sort of a oh we have
to believe this because of this or
because it uh you know we have to
believe this because it disagrees with
some religious uh belief or we have to
believe that because it's better for you
know the government winning in this way
or that way or and so on those forces
from outside of science are are super
difficult I would say for science to
deal with and and most scientists are
pretty naive in in trying to deal with
those things and I think in in some
places you know there's plenty of places
which I could start describing but there
they're often sort of politically
charged things which I personally try to
stay out of but there are plenty of
things where you know from a science
point of view it's like look I'm pretty
sure this is just nonsense but
nevertheless it has a a big weight of
kind of political force on it that uh
says you can't you can't say it's
nonsense and and it's difficult to deal
with that and I think that sometimes it
um uh it really you just have to wait
for often quite long periods of time for
those forces to dissipate I mean
certainly in the
uh there were you know forces arrayed
against for example relativity theory
that were partly scientific I mean this
is back in the early part of the 20th
century partly scientific partly kind of
uh political effectively of um uh you
know what was the you know was it good
German science or was it Jewish science
was it this was it that um you know I
think it's it's a very I my own feeling
is that that it's it's a uh one of the
nice things about science is that it
does have a certain internal kind of
validity to it that really is quite
independent of who made it
up sometimes it's really important to
understand who made it up and to
understand kind of the context and the
historical lineage to understand even
what the science is but in the end the
science is the science and it kind of
Rises or you know stands or falls on its
own merits it doesn't really matter who
made it up and how shocking the person
was who made it up or how uh you know
politically you know sort of supported
they were or whatever else but it
sometimes takes a long time for the kind
of uh uh that you know those influences
to kind of dissipate
and usually what happens in the in the
course of history is that in the end all
that people remember is the science
sometimes attributed to the wrong person
but all they remember is the science the
Bloodshed associated with whatever
produced that science is long forgotten
and and so that um uh um that was
um uh you know so that that ends up
being sort of the ironic final twist is
that in the end the sort of validity of
Science and its own and its own uh you
know standing for itself is the thing
that survives the centuy so to speak and
all the details of who uh you know who
was the uh uh you know sort of who won
and who lost in the French Revolution or
whatever else um is all completely uh
you know
disappears let's see a couple more
things here maybe I can try and do and
then we should wrap up here
um
what does the modern history of science
tell us asks Arie about non-academic
contributors and the future of these
types of
contributions well one thing to say is
that if you look at Major advances in
pretty much
everything they rarely come from the
center of heavily professionalized
Fields not never but maybe I'm going to
say half the time
maybe but some large fraction of the
time they come from something that came
from outside that field you know a field
gets this big inertia of this is what we
do in our field and there is a machine
that makes incremental progress and over
the course of decades that incremental
progress can really add up to quite a
lot but when it's a dramatic kind of oh
there's this exciting new thing it
usually comes from introducing something
a set of ideas a way of thinking about
things that wasn't part of the big
inertia of that field and so it's often
the case that sort of new ideas come
from people who are sort of a little bit
at best interstitial and sometimes from
outside of field X now are they from
outside of academic science sometimes um
I would say that that that's there's
been a sort of constant drum beat of
that throughout history um it's back in
you know a few hundred years ago it was
hard to make a living as a professional
scientist some people did you know Isaac
Newton was a professional scientist
Lucasian professor of mathematics in
Cambridge uh at least until later in his
life when he when he up you know
upscaled so to speak to be the
controller of the mint in England a
better paying more prestigious job um
and uh but but that was um um I think
the uh uh it was you know most people
were not you know livets was not a
professional scientist he was a
professional courtier so to speak who
would do kind of Consulting about
history or this or that or the other for
dukes and he did science on the side or
mathematics and so on on the philosophy
on the side uh most it's it's only in in
quite recent times that there really is
a track for for being a professional
scientist and it's worth remembering
that there's only a track for being a
professional scientist in the
professionalized fields of science so
for example there are plenty of areas
like things I've worked on like what I
now call rology the study of the effect
of simple rules in the computational
universe and what they do that's an
interesting one because it's something
that kind of I really pushed in the
early 1980s bunch of people got involved
in it there's probably 500 people who've
made cont contributions to that and they
span all these different academic areas
as well as non-academic areas and their
contributions may be in papers they may
be on websites they may have not been
published in a form where other people
can find them it's very very scattered
because that field is not yet maybe it
will become so a heavy profession
heavily professionalized field there'll
come a time when people are professors
of that get degrees in that where there
are professional societies of that and
so on and at that point the picture will
probably change but you know in one of
these young Fields it's inevitable that
there are nonprofessionals because the
field doesn't really exists so I think
the
um uh now in terms of people who make a
living as software Engineers or Quant
Finance people or something else who
make significant contributions to to
science U that absolutely happens it
happens with varying degrees of of
success in different areas so for
example as I say it's much easier for
that to happen in a young field you know
there was a period of time in the late
1800s for example in natural history
when you know it was all amateurs of
various kinds and but it was you know I
think in today's world it's much more
you know there's a professional
expedition to the depths of the Jungle
and so on more so than an amateur uh
kind of oh I'm just going to go to the
jungle and and pick up these things of
Beatles and so on um I think it depends
on the field you know in astronomy
there's been a long history of kind of
amateur astronomers discovering
astronomical phenomena my guess is that
will come to an end because there will
be you know there are beginning to be
very good systematic Sky surveys every
day and you know the amateur who notices
that Comet or that variable star or some
other thing that they're just you know a
big sky to cover and they haven't been
automated systems to cover it that will
come to an end I think that um in
something like mathematics it's pretty
hard to make a Frontline Discovery in
mathematics if you're an amateur now
there are different kinds of amateurs
because there are amateurs who are fully
trained but they make a living doing
something else and there are people who
who didn't sort of go through and learn
the existing Cannon and are now
contribute trying to contribute to
something I think that second category
it works much better in a younger fi
field it's certainly possible in rology
to be absolutely of that kind because
there isn't a deep Canon of of uh uh of
work in something like some obscure area
well not obscure some some deep area of
mathematics like I don't know number
theory for example it's pretty difficult
to make a Frontline contribution sort of
coming from the outside I would argue if
you use computers and you do
mathematical experiments it might be a
bit easier because that's something that
hasn't been well picked over by the main
sort of main bulk of mathematicians but
I think and this is a place where where
things get sort of complicated I mean I
don't know in in um uh if you look at
people who are making contributions in
machine learning for instance they come
from all different places a young field
well it's not that young a field but in
its current form it's a young field but
the people who are doing that are coming
from all over the place and many of them
you would say well it's sort of a
science contribution but they're they're
absolutely not sort of professionally
employed to do that kind of
science I think in um of people who are
sort of trained but don't do science for
a living there aren't as many as you
might hope uh and I was thinking I I
know many of them I mean because such
people I suppose I'm an example of this
um you know one of the features is that
that I can do science that is quite
ambitious and quite uh it doesn't follow
the incremental steps because I'm not
going out and and writing Grant
proposals to you know support my next
incremental step that the peer reviewers
will understand so to speak I can kind
of do whatever I want and um uh you know
try some much more uh sort of uh much
more ambitious direction in science and
and I've been lucky enough to be able to
do that for many years now and and
that's been critical I mean to my uh
success in discovering things has been
that I can do that um and that's a
consequence of the fact that I don't
make my living uh sort of producing
science professoring whatever else um I
think that the number of people who are
in a situation like mine where you know
they sort of professionally know the
science but they're not but and they're
doing science but they're not doing it
as a profession so to speak that number
is rather small and I I think I know in
for example physical science I probably
know most of maybe I'm maybe I'm wrong
about that but I certainly know a good
collection of such people uh I would say
that that it really varies with the
field I mean what you know in medicine
for example there are lots and lots of
practicing doctors who do a bit of
research on the side and that's a place
where you I don't know whether that
counts as amateur or not I mean you know
there they're MDS but they're not phds
and they're not at a research facility
they're they're just you know doctors at
a hospital somewhere but they're doing
some research on the side that's a
pretty common thing and I don't know how
much that counts and I don't really know
in in I think it really depends I mean
you know it would be hard to be an
amateur experimental partical physicist
because if your equipment costs a
billion dollars a pop it's it's just not
something amateurs can do um at least
very few amateurs can do
that and I think um so uh
I would say that in the the respect for
non-academic contributors to science has
varied over time in if you looked at you
know fellows of the Royal Society back
100 and something years ago you would
find well but in the 1800s you would
find many people who were in absolutely
no way professional scientists whereas
I'm sure if you look today the vast vast
majority I I was noticing this
uh couple of different things some
honorific thing that that uh uh I I got
elected to I was noticing that you know
if I looked at the list of all the
people there I was almost the only one
who wasn't employed to be a
scientist
um and uh so you know maybe it's it's
quite rare modern times uh I'm happy to
be able to do that because as I say it
allows one to do much more ambitious big
picture kinds of things um and because
one's only you know one one's taking
one's own resources and betting on those
ambitious kinds of things rather than
saying well we're going to use
government money for this or or
something like
that
um yeah Pontius comments it's not just
science where new ideas take time to
settle van go famous famously sold only
one paint painting during his lifetime
yes I mean indeed it happens in all
areas and and the challenge is that the
good ideas not get
lost because you know there can be good
things that are done and they're just
washed away in the tide of history I
mean one person I've studied quite a bit
is L boltzman kind of
uh originator of many things in
statistical mechanics and things related
to the second or of th dnamic
and also a big believer in atoms and
molecules discreetness of matter and
people didn't believe in the
discreetness of matter in the 1800s when
boltzman mostly worked and boltzman uh
who was quite became kind of a
philosopher in his later years and and
wrote quite eloquent things uh famously
was like I'm going to record what I have
to say about atomism this was around
1900 because
um uh you know he he says you know one
man cannot withstand the tide of history
but I'm going to write down what I know
about atomism because uh when these
ideas are are rediscovered in the future
um hopefully not too much will have been
lost so he said um and uh boltzman sadly
uh killed himself in 1906 um uh not I
think because people were attacking his
theories but for psychiatric kinds of
reasons not not related to kind of EX
forces um the I think that um uh it was
sort of
sad in many ways but particularly
because you know 1905 was when Einstein
wrote his paper about the interpretation
of Brownian motion in terms of molecules
and that was the time when the tide
really started to turn on the atomic
theory of matter and boltzman died just
just you know just too early to see that
and then indeed boltzman was right that
his work on on the molecular theory of
matter uh was you know rediscovered so
to speak it it it it it because his for
example lectures on gas Theory which was
one of his his things was was had not
been gone for long it was people still
knew about it there was still a
generation of people who'd known
boltzman known his work and so on it
wasn't kind of lost for five generations
I I think there probably are things
which are lost for five generations or
five academic generations and then it's
it's pretty hard to reconstitute them I
mean I think uh well uh you know for
example I've often wondered whether
livets came how close lienet came to
inventing the idea of universal
computation I I even went through his
archive trying to look for for evidence
of of that um I don't know I don't think
he came that close but had he come close
that would have been an idea lost for
centuries um before it was it was
refound another idea that I know was
lost is the idea of fractals and nested
patterns which was originated uh
certainly there were people one
particular group of people Mosaic layers
who were creating such patterns in the
1200s early 1200s and that idea was kind
of lost for basically well close to 600
years so
uh that's that's really the issue is do
the good ideas actually
survive uh or are they are they
rediscovered independent of their
original form and that's and sometimes
then when people do the history they say
oh my gosh this person had this idea
back in the day and you know nobody knew
that and and so it's it's really a a
fresh Discovery so to
speak
um let's see I need to off in a moment
here I think
um the
uh uh Adam asks how how and why should
we document science in the future when
AI starts to lead
progress well I think um uh
[Music]
um you know the idea of AI leading
progress is a complicated one
because there are an infinite number of
directions for progress and the choice
of which ones we take is not a choice
that is a that is ultimately going to be
a human choice for us it's kind of the
you know the AI can mechanize how we do
it but what we choose if the AI chooses
we're going to say and and and indeed
something I've done a lot is have have
computationally just go out into the
universe of possible programs and see
what's out there and see what they do
and one of the things that happens is
most of what's out there is really alien
to us humans and we're like yeah that's
kind of an interesting picture I don't
know what it
means and until there's a kind of human
connection to these things it's kind of
like the AI are going off and exploring
this infinite world of possibilities
most of which we just shrug our
shoulders and say why does anybody care
now that that so I think that a uh in a
sense this is already a problem for us
that in this field of rology that I've
talking about about studying simple
programs and what they do there's an
infinite number of those to study just
like in mathematics there's an infinite
number of theorems one could prove but
one question is which of these are
actually ones that we humans kind of
care about and are ones that we are
going to bring into our kind of Arc of
intellectual history that's a thing that
is I think not something it's it's
intrinsically not something that AI can
can do it's just going to go out and
explore everything I for example one
project I have recently is um uh to see
whether AI can tell whether mathematical
theorem will be considered interesting
by humans it's like you've seen the 3
million theorems humans have written
down
now ai tell me this random theorem that
I produced will the humans find it
interesting so far we haven't managed to
get very far with that so far that's
been a big flop it's really hard to tell
it feels very historical so to
speak okay
so uh all right one last there's a
question here from a incomprehensible
handle what are the positives of
reformulating
History you know history is hard and
really understanding The Narrative of
what
happens is I think very revealing for
understanding the richness and depth of
ideas and sometimes you don't get the
history right first time around
sometimes the I mean this need to
reformulate history sometimes it's a
purely you know political ideological
kind of thing but sometimes it's just
because for example one common reason is
at some point we really understand
something we understand some scientific
point then we can go back and see oh now
I can see why this or that fell this way
because we Now understand the science
for real so to speak but we didn't
understand it before when that history
was first being formulated people didn't
know that that particular aspect of it
was important or what that really meant
so that's a reason that you know knowing
what we know now we can go back and see
how all these pieces fit together we
couldn't have seen earlier in time also
it's just can be difficult I mean I know
even history that I myself have been
involved in it's kind of often
challenging to see what was the bigger
picture of what actually happened I'll
give you a couple of examples I mean for
example I started working on kind of
simple programs in the computational
universe and how they produce complex
behavior and so on I started working on
that right after this is 1981 1980 right
after IID spent a bunch of time
developing my first big computer system
I think called S&P for hunner of
mathematical morm language um and so I
you know it's like it's a it's an
interesting coincidence in time that I
was working on this computer system and
then I start working on this kind of
computational way of thinking about
science and I realized after the fact
that before I worked on that computer
system the science I'd done was science
where you start from the natural world
and you try and drill down and see what
it's made of
what I did in building that computer
system was something purely con
constructive sort of you know starting
from nothing build the structure and
what I realized is it was doing that
that allowed me kind of the intellectual
freedom to say let me just invent a
theory from nothing and just look at the
space of all possible theories and see
what they imply the idea of just looking
at a space of all possible theories was
not an idea that occurred to me when
what I was doing and what I thought I
was doing in science is to start from
the world as it is and drill down to see
kind of The Primitives from which that's
made so in a sense that and it took me
oh gosh I don't know decades after that
time to kind of thread together those
pieces of History even the construction
of S&P which now has well many many
resonances with the construction of w
from language um the even that took me
years to understand that in a sense S&P
was constructed very differently from
the way that people had constructed kind
of computer languages in the past and I
realized that that again after many
years after the fact I kind of realized
that why was that that I done something
differently well the answer was because
I was used to doing Natural Science
where what you do is you take a set of
phenomena and you try and drill down and
find their Primitives and that was
essentially what I was trying to do for
computation take the computations people
want to do and drill down and find their
Primitives and build those into the
language but it took me many years after
the fact to realize that was the history
so to speak rather than oh uh you know I
just happened to develop this and you
know I you know happen to have these
ideas wasn't wasn't the case at all um
and and I think why is it useful to
reformulate things in those ways it's
useful because then you really
understand what was the flow of thought
that happened there and that's useful to
me at least in understanding well you
know what are the flows of thought that
you know are are realistic to have today
I mean you know when we see oh I don't
know the arrival of the llms the arrival
of kind of generative Ai and so on uh
you know what how do we think about that
what's really going on here what you
know what will be the you know in the
long term what will be seen as the
significance of all of that I think it's
it's particularly What's significant is
what it tells us about the structure of
particularly human language and so on
that's the big sort of science Discovery
from that um and uh you know you can
kind of uh I don't know so so
understanding some of these sort of what
fits with what in in history in the past
helps one to sort of get a better idea
of the big picture
today well I should wrap up here and uh
PAB is is uh commenting that um saying
Happy New Year and um yes I'm not sure
let me just see when are we next um
uh on here I think we get a we get one
more live stream for the year on Friday
afternoon um I believe and uh after that
we're on to a new year and I have to uh
um I have uh yes there are all sorts of
interesting things that I'm hoping will
happen uh in the new year and um I
certainly um I have a lot of work to do
of things that I'm trying to make happen
in the new year but anyway we should uh
wrap it up for now here um thank you uh
all for for joining me and uh see you
again another time bye for
now